[MUSIC]
For as long as I can remember,
there have been two people inside my head
whispering to me.
Now, I wanna introduce them to you, and
I think the best way to do that is with an
experience I had last year,
in probably my least favorite place in the
entire world.
The customer service line at United
Airlines.
[LAUGH].
Now I had gotten to SFO and
hour early to have plenty of time to make
my direct flight to JFK.
I was looking forward to landing late that
evening and
getting a good night sleep before my
friends wedding the following afternoon.
Instead, as I was going through security I
got a text from United saying
my flight was cancelled for airplane
maintenance.
I rush to the customer service line where
after waiting my turn, the woman
behind the counter told me there was no
way I could get to New York before Sunday.
My response?
Wait, you're telling me it'll take two
days to get from San Francisco to
New York?
That can't be right, please check again.
The woman did not take kindly to my tone.
[LAUGH].
And pushed a few buttons before telling me
I could take a two layover trip, and
make the tail end of the reception, take
it or leave it.
I tried after the fact to be friendly, but
couldn't get any other options and I took
it.
Later I found out a friend behind me in
line had patiently managed
to get a one lay over trip and make the
ceremony.
So that's what happened outside my head
out in the world, but
here's what happened with those two people
inside my head.
Now the first person, imagine him
whispering to me from my left shoulder,
I call the eager updater.
I got to the airport, saw the cancellation
text, and
the eager updater chimed right into my
head.
He said, hm, you know, it looks like the
plane we
expected to take us to New York isn't
going there after all.
[LAUGH].
Good to know, what's our best option now?
As I dealt with the customer service lady,
the eager updater immediately noticed,
she wasn't the instant ally I had been
counting on.
[LAUGH].
He said.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Good to know.
Now we can adjust our approach to get the
best outcome
from the woman who is in front of us and
not the woman we thought she'd be.
Pretty mature, right?
Kind of suspicious though.
Like, if the eager updater was whispering
all of this useful stuff to me,
how come I acted so ineffectively.
Well, that's where the second person in my
head comes in.
[LAUGH].
I call him the king of wishful thinking.
Imagine him whispering to me from my right
shoulder.
Now, the king of wishful thinking saw the
cancellation text and
he too chimed right into my head.
He said this shouldn't be happening.
We were just about to be on our way to New
York and
now we have to deal with a frustrating day
of travel hassle.
Every minute I stood in the customer
service line,
the king of wishful thinking was
whispering reminders to me.
You know we'd expected to be in the air by
now.
[LAUGH].
By now, we'd be over Colorado on our way
to a nice warm hotel room.
As I dealt with the customer service lady,
the king of wishful thinking said to me,
if someone competent was back there, we
would, they would have fixed this by now.
This shouldn't be happening.
[LAUGH].
So those are the two folks whispering in
my head all the time.
The eager updater with his various forms
of, good to know.
And the king of wishful thinking riffing
on his awesome catch-phrase,
this shouldn't be happening.
And if these guys are starting to sound
familiar to you, they should because
these two characters are whispering in
your head all the time too.
The eager updater and the king of wishful
thinking are just
two ways our brains are wired to receive
and process information.
Over the past couple of years, I've gotten
really interested in the neuroscience and
psychology behind how we handle
situations.
And I've been studying in particular this
duality between perception and
expectation.
I gave names and
personalities to these mental processes
really just to help me more easily apply
what I've learned to begin to make better
decisions in my own life.
And I wanna share them with you because I
think that getting
more acquainted with these guys in each of
our heads can help us handle,
be, be more effective in handling a wide
variety of situations we face every day.
So I think of the eager updater as this
guy that openly seeks
out new information to update our view of
what is happening in any situation.
He plugs into our five senses to, to add
more data, so we can better understand,
accept and respond to the real world in
which we operate.
The king of wishful thinking, on the other
hand,
filters every experience we have through
the lens of our expectations.
Our hopes, our beliefs, our anticipations
about what will happen, or
what should happen in any situation.
Now maybe you're having visions right now
of old cartoons with an eager updater
angel on one shoulder and a king of
wishful thinking devil on the other.
That's not fair to the king of wishful
thinking.
[LAUGH].
We evolved this expectation lens for very
good reasons.
For one being able to set a future goal
and
hold it in mind, keeps us motivated and
proactive as we work to achieve it.
It also keeps us mentally efficient.
Allowing us to focus on just the most
relevant parts of our surroundings.
The neuroscience research for
example, suggests that our eyes actually
use our expectations to fill out most
of what we see with just small amounts of
new data informing the picture.
The problem,
though, is that even though the king of
wishful thinking is useful and necessary,
he does have a tendency to get much louder
than our eager updater and drown him out.
And that's what happened with my
experience with United Airlines.
But this tendency applies well beyond
changing travel plans.
So for example, an over assertive king of
wishful thinking,
contributed to my staying in relationships
too long.
When I clung to an image of the girl I
hoped I was dating, and filtered out
the information the real world that was
showing me something different.
Or beyond my own personal experience,
I was chatting about this topic last month
with an entrepreneur here in the Valley,
who immediately recognized the king of
wishful thinking in himself.
As the number one reason his first startup
hadn't taken off.
For one thing,
he said, he had really wanted all of his
early employees to be high performers.
And so, didn't acknowledge soon enough
that some of them were not and
act quickly to course correct.
Similarly, he said he had expected that
the product offering he'd come up with
would be very difficult to replicate.
And so it wasn't attentive to the
competitors that started to enter and
gain market share.
Now, hopefully, each of these experiences
reinforces that our king of wishful
thinking can be a loud and damaging part
of our psychology and our neurophysiology.
But that doesn't mean we just have to
throw up our hands.
The research suggests there are two
relatively simple steps we can take
to bring him more inline.
And the first step is simply to recognize
that we all have
a king of wishful thinking whispering
inside our heads all the time.
And be aware when he might be getting too
dominant.
Now here the signs suggest there are five
emotions that are the most useful red
flags for this.
And as I list them think about a time you
recently felt these.
Frustration, anger, jealousy,
irritation, disappointment, recognize
those?
[LAUGH].
I know I felt three or four of them before
breakfast.
[LAUGH].
Well, it turns out these are signals of an
overaggressive king of wishful thinking,
basically telling us that there's
something that we were hoping for or
expecting from reality that isn't there.
Basically telling us this shouldn't be
happening.
The second step then is, in those
situations, to summon a more attentive and
assertive eager updater.
And the main strategy here is to open out
our perceptual field, by asking questions
like, how might I respond differently now,
given the new information available?
Or by responding to the King's, this
shouldn't be happening,
with this is happening, good to know.
[LAUGH].
With just these two steps, we can change
the way we experience the setbacks and
opportunities in our lives, with the
benefit of a more clear-sighted and
constructed view of what's going on around
us.
And that's my hope for myself, and it's my
hope for each of you,
that next time you're working hard to
solve a complex problem, or
grow a promising company, or take the next
step in a relationship, or
heaven forbid, reschedule a flight on
United.
[LAUGH].
I hope you stop, take a mental step back,
and readjust the volume
setting of the two companions whispering
from your shoulders.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]